e e
good morning
everybody morning happy
Friday um it is 10 o'clock I'm going to
open
the I am not going to open yet I'm going
to ask everybody to rise uh join us for
the Pledge of Allegiance thank you for
the reminder Madam
clerk I'm
here I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all now I'm going to open the public
hearing for House Bill 91 is that right
yeah 91 um and invite our
sponsor is that you that is not
you well
would you like me to introduce it
representative PR I would love for you
to introduce this bill I think you might
know something about it yeah I love it
okay
I okay I don't even have this
spill I I I have it I just good morning
Madam chair and the rest of the
committee Mark PR Hillsboro 15
introducing a bill
that just starting to read now so
apparently this says that uh
municipalities can give out permits for
fireworks
display and that the fire department
will have the ability to inspect the
site and the fire chief will get to
determine whether fire apparatus and
Personnel need to be there in case of an
emergency and they determine how long
that presence needs to be
there thank you representative I'm
assuming that you probably aren't the
best person to ask questions you would
assume correctly but I imagine I could
get through a little bit see so would
everybody be okay if we just give
representative PR a second to look over
this because he would be our expert in
the room when it when it comes to this
we might be able to so usually most
firework displays need to have fire
personnel there but I and I'm not sure
if this is going more towards the
private person looking to do something
in their backyard as opposed to a
municipality putting on the Fourth of
July fireworks so I'm not really sure
but in the question of should there be
fire apparatus there with Personnel
depending on how big the display is and
how big the fireworks they are using
what class they are uh you definitely
want somebody there when they go
bad and they do go bad from time to
time me V to
allower and so that are you reading this
that it would that it would be that it
would go on the ballot for the voting
body to decide that whether to give
permits or not yeah so so the towns as
far as I understand it towns right now
have the ability to say yes we're GNA
have fireworks in our town and allow
them or no we're not right and that's
for I believe for the private
user again I'm just kind of winging this
as we go yeah that that's okay I think
we are we appreciate
you
um all right
so give me a second I want to does
anybody does anybody have any questions
just looking at this that or any input
that they would like to
add representative
Newman even Mike even though they choose
to have the presence there they might
not not they might allow for the
fireworks and have the presence there is
that that might be so the to as I read
this the town can say yes you can have
fireworks right the fire chief will be
allowed to come look at that site to see
what you're actually using for fireworks
because there are different
classes basically from small to big
commercial um and he gets to decide
whether fire apparatus and Personnel
need to be
there and how long they need to be there
CU even after you're done shooting off
the fireworks if some of them haven't
gone off you have to wait till they cool
down a certain amount of time and then
you can uh make Rend of them
safe thank
you all right oh representative Murray
thank you Murphy representative Murphy
close enough thank you um thank you
representative proof for taking my
question
um in do you know now if do fire um
Chiefs not have the ability to determine
whether uh to to inspect the site and
determine whether or not they so I
believe when it comes to private home
fireworks yeah no if it's a
commercial uh shoot with the
professionals doing it uhcl uh using
commercial fireworks we are required to
be
there we are required to inspect
it follow up thank you so this is likely
than just for private F okay I have to
look at the Statue also refen thank
you sir are you by any chance here for
this particular Bill do you think maybe
you could help clear up some of our
confusion that would be that would be so
super thank you representative
PR I I'm I'm looking at his face
everybody he's like please just let me
come up just get the guy out of there
how did he
do did you understand what it was about
did you leave us
hanging when you're when you're finished
if you could just please make sure oh is
this the paint card here yes awesome
okay if you could just state your name
um and if you are either opposed or
support the bill and then help us out be
awesome yes thank you madam chair and
the rest of the committee my name is
Philip Byron I am a deputy fire marshal
for the office of State Fire Marshal um
we are in neutral of this bill um our
office is okay with making a change from
the current administrative rules to
provide the local fire chief with
flexibility around the scheduling of the
fire details our interest is that an
inspection is completed and it makes
sense to have resources available at the
time of display current administrative r
R says the detail is on site from their
time of arrival to completion of the
display any
questions yes so
that what you just said is for a munici
like a
municipality that is setting off
professional fireworks this is for I
want to put off fireworks in my backyard
because it's Fourth of July so according
to the verbiage it does say sight of a
display show or sight of the display so
that typically Ally means your
1.3 larger shows that cons uh the
companies put on not your typical home
shows so if you want to shoot something
in your backyard you go to a fireworks
store you'll buy the one point4 consumer
product that is not the intent from what
I understand of this bill this is more
for the
display and it gives the fire department
the option of when to arrive and it it
if I may
so I was understanding from
representative PR that they already have
to be present that's correct safy this
is given them the option of whether they
have to stay there the whole time I
understand thank you it gives them more
flexibility safc 5024 do10 is fire
equipment that is under the display
fireworks rules which dis that discusses
and outlines the requirement for
firework detail at this time
okay so just you got everything I
said pretty much I think you got the
time period right I think you did you
did such a good job representative PR
we're so proud of you representative
Murphy oh thank you thanks for taking my
question and thank you for your help
around
this yeah um can you tell me the the
language is a sight of the display I
heard what you just said um and I I I'm
just wondering if that could be
if a citizen could just say well this is
the site where my display is going to be
if if that language needs to be more
specific to around to distinguish
whether the fire department has to show
up at a local local residence
wait wait yeah so local res residences
so like representative was mentioning
the local authorities do have ordinances
in place in their communities to allow
or disallow fireworks
for
anyone um when it comes to local
homeowners they're able to the local
municipality allows it to utilize
fireworks a firework detail would not be
required for that for personal use if it
was a display show or anyone doing
anything larger than that where the
Public's involved things like that
that's where a detto may come into place
thank you
representativ do you have anything to
add that might help us out here just any
questions because it seemed like you you
knew but you were over there being so
quiet okay uh representative
Muse I I do have a question I know we
have a we have a neighbor that about two
or three times a year uh puts on a show
that uh in some years almost puts the
Portsmouth uh City fireworks display to
shame um it will go on for over a half
an hour
um most of the same stuff pretty much
everything you would see in the
Portsmouth display which is a pretty
good one uh uh you'll see from uh from
the the dock over and back of our
property
um how do you know I mean what what what
sort of where's the where does is there
a line between what's acceptable for a
private homeowner and these public
display requirements that are more
commercially oriented said when the
homeowner is putting on a display that's
pretty much at the level of Comm a
commercial display so yes it's the te
technology these days is very difficult
to distinguish between a display show
and consumer show because a consumer
product is so welldeveloped now that it
looks like a display show so that maybe
is what you're seeing at in your
location um it it does happen quite
frequently throughout the
state and what would and what would the
impact of this bill be if any on that
type of
display nothing this is this is more for
display shoot so a company comes in like
Port Smith and they uh they have a
company set up to do a shoot for a
public event then a firework detail
would follow this law and they do with
this bill they do that anyway right so
okay thank you you're welcome sounds
like we all need to go to Portsmith for
a free Fire display
from America okay are there any other
questions no thank you very much
appreciate the information thank you for
your
time is there is there anybody here that
wishes to give us some testimony on
House Bill 91 not not what you guys are
here for okay all right seeing none I
will close the public hearing for house
and we will be in recess for about 45
minutes friends uh 11:00 is our next
hearing
e
e e
I'm opening the public hearing on House
Bill 143 and I invite the prime sponsor
to come and introduce the
bill House Bill
143 who's the Prime
sponsor John James Jackson um
I'm going to uh recess this hearing for
10 minutes and see if we can't locate
one of the uh
sponsors
e
e e
okay I'm reopening the public hearing on
House Bill 143 and I invite the Pim
swans to come and introduce her
bill um thank you members of the
committee and I
apologize uh for my mixup of time um my
name is uh representative Juliet Harvey
bully I represent bellnap County
District 3 and um I am uh bringing to
you house bill 143 regarding no trespass
orders um let me just let me just get
this going here um and the Genesis of
this bill
is uh for me it's it's multiple things
but most recently it was a case in
Bow uh this year uh and you have the um
printed out from inside sources two
strikes for B fathers of school issues
second no trespass order so this bill
addresses um how
municipalities and U towns address no
trespass orders on public property not
private
property um what happened was two
parents were issued um no trespass
orders um over uh this this past year I
believe those orders have been rescinded
and there's been core cases since then
um to deal with the fact that their 14th
Amendment uh rights were violated so
what this addresses is the the pro the
problem of lack of due process with
regards to this uh section of law um we
have a 14th Amendment right which
establishes that people require due
process when they are given uh orders no
trespass
orders and it is also in our New
Hampshire
Constitution um requiring a process of
uh due process uh when they have these
issues uh these orders issued so I give
you the um inside
sources print out here and on the back
you'll see the actual um no trespass
order
just for your
um your review the problem is with these
and many others in New Hampshire um is
that they lack any sort of
um uh notice to the plaintiff if you
will um of that they can
um appeal this
judgment um so this is what uh this
spill seeks to
remedy is the appeal process and also
setting into place um more rigid
requirements and
specificity uh the second thing in the
packet is a uh print out about gen in
general about no trespass orders by the
ACLU um I believe Massachusetts has had
quite a few cases regarding this um
issue
and if you do a little bit of research
you'll find that all states have some
sort of due process when it comes to no
no trespass orders on public property or
on any property for that matter
um and then the third thing here is a
specific case in New
Hampshire you see a ACLU and your
packet um it is a specific case
regarding uh plane Jeffrey Pendleton
from 2014 he was a homeless
person um that was outside of a
Nashville
library um he was given a no a verbal no
trespass order without any sort of
indate or um appeal process offered to
him um and
so he
actually ended up being in jail for 33
days um because of it but the case found
that his rights were violated um
specifically the 14th the US uh 14th
Amendment um and also um our statute
also um requires that they have due
process so if you flip to page8 and N
where I have it sectioned off of a pink
note um
down on page eight second and third pray
uh where it says second and
third those are the
um findings that pertain to this bill
here um the department the police
department provided no meaningful
opportunity for Mr Pendleton to contest
the removal of his
rights
um and it's citing some other cases and
then third the no trespass order was
issued without any narrow objective
standards or criteria regarding when the
issuance um of the no trespass order is
appropriate and what its scope or
duration should be so a lot of these
orders I'm hearing are they're coming
down they have no end
date um they're not specific they're not
narrow in the case of uh the bow the the
case in Bow if you read about it um the
parent in question here was prohibited
from entering buildings ground even the
parking
lot F Fields until further notice no end
date no appeal process
whatsoever um now we can fix this and
stop some of these prevent some of these
lawsuits from coming through it's just
it's just
unnecessary um I'm giving you you also
see a no trespassing order this is from
the uh town of
molteno but there's dozens people have
sent me dozens of these from
municipalities they're all the
same it's
just name of unwanted person here's the
order this order will remain into effect
until you receive written permission
blah blah blah no uh no appeal process
at all no
hearing
um and a couple other
things um this is uh it says Northampton
it's Massachusetts this is not really
pertaining to the bill directly but it's
an example of how after multiple um sort
of constitutional cases in St
Massachusetts that were regarding this s
same subject a school district has taken
upon themselves to uh craft a very
specific policy that would protect
people's constitutional rights with
regard to issuance of no trespass orders
um
they have according to this policy the
school system must exhaust efforts to
resolve the issues it's a temporary
order with specific um time limits Etc
so it's just um this is just for your
sort of
um understanding of the whole issue
might not be particular to this case
here um and so
that is uh pretty much it is just I'm
going to grab the
C so this bill is being
um was given to me by the school
governance
Association um and what it it uh
provides
for is that until an order is um issued
the unanimous vote of a g governing body
in a duly notice public meeting shall
take place uh so the
person subject to the order shall have
the right to the hearing with the
governing body in a non-public or public
section session and um shall shall be uh
before such a a vote by the governing
body um and then there's a process for
further appealing if need be now I I
realize that there's probably people
here uh from libraries and whatnot I
know libraries across our
state they use these blanket no trespass
orders quite frequently for um unhoused
people and whatnot that end up in their
libraries um but I would contend that
there still should be a process in place
there should be due process in our
statute um to provide
for everybody
who is on public property and
and might have this sort of order that
uh comes
down so um with that I'll take any
questions thank you um I wonder if if
it's not possible to to do both so I see
in the bill it says that it may not
issue until there's been a unanimous
vote of the governing body um which in
itself is a very high bar because you
may have some someone who just refuses
to ever get vote for one of these and
the agency may never get an own trespass
order so that's that's one thing but put
a pin in that what about the time it
takes for the governing body to convene
and get one of these orders issued
sometimes you have people that are very
disruptive and maybe even dangerous for
example at a library you could have
someone who's in their emotionally
disturbed person you know children are
there would it not be possible to for
them to be able to um issue one on an
emergency basis and then have to have it
only good until the next meeting where
then they could go over it and vote on
it and then still leave the the appeal
process in in place that way they could
deal with somebody who was causing a
problem right away but that person would
still have their ability for due process
what are your thoughts about that thank
you Mr chair um yes I I think that's how
it's done in some states of doing a
little research and I I asked OS to kind
of of uh weigh in on this as well I
asked told OLS is possible that U
amendment is coming forward um to sort
of address maybe a temporary um no
trespassing order and then the have the
the hearing process go forward and and
then also there's there's an issue of
should it be unanimous or should it be a
majority yeah um I would be friendly to
any sort of discussion in that regard we
work on the bill whatever the committee
decides okay great that's good because
I'm concerned that high bar if you get
you could have one person who just hates
no trespass orders and the agency would
just be unable to ever do anything um
and you are meable to possibly um having
an emergency procedure thank you uh
questions from the committee uh
representative
Sher okay uh first I I agree with the
the chair's comments I think that's
having a a temporary emergency process
uh with a finite and at the until the
the whoever the governing body is can
meet I I think that's a great idea and I
would be in favor also of a a majority
vote the question I have is tangentially
related um is Jeffrey Pendleton if I
understand if I remember correctly
Jeffrey P Pendleton died in jail that
correct um I it's said that he served
his
sentence I I didn't see anything about
that here I'll check on that irrelevant
to this but I'm just curious there's
some other cases in here in the back too
that I think pertain to NASA
but okay yeah sorry representative
n thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I I you know
clearly um there isn't a fiscal note
attached to this because it wouldn't be
an expense to the state but I think it
would be an ex uh an expense to um
notice and to have you know having a a
public meeting requires certain things
uh for a town or a municipality um and
employing people streaming it having it
public things like that um have you
given any thought or do you have any
numbers for as far as what this would
cost the
municipality uh thank you for your
question representative n um that would
be sort of up to the committee as far as
time frames so if the committee decides
that they should have a
hearing at at a date certain after the
order or at the next um scheduled
meeting so for instance somebody gets an
order no trespassing
order the law can simply read you know
at the next scheduled hearing or within
10 days the subject shall be granted a
hearing I don't think it would cost
anything extra because you still have to
notice for those meetings anyway so
given that they meet maybe once a month
or twice a month I don't see that as
unreasonable um but um no I have not uh
flushed out any costs if that's what you
mean can I follow up okay um because it
seems to me like the the process is laid
out here and one of the things that is
laid out is um having a um public or
non-public at the election of the person
um having um a meeting with the
governing body in advance of that public
meeting so that is in addition uh to
what would happen and it does need to be
duly noticed um I would assume for that
purpose as well um so that the public
could be ready for it but what I am
saying is that it I don't think that all
of these things fit under um under the
scope of of what would already be
happening so it would already be an
expense to you
agree um I don't think it would um I I
think it's it depends on the
municipality how they want to handle it
I guess it could be extremely expensive
if you had hours and hours worth of uh
attorney fees however it is the 14th
Amendment we're talking about so I don't
really see it's a federal requirement
within our constitution to have due
process so I don't really know how
there's any getting around
it okay yeah and also appealing to the
supre court I'm sure that would be a
right and and this this measure I mean
this is going to be a cost-saving
measure if nothing else I I hope um for
the municipalities it's a simple thing
uh to provide for due process and it it
doesn't need to be
costly um I don't think lawyers need to
be involved but lawyers could be
involved and that I guess that's all I
can say to say about that thank you
thank
you representative
sh yes thank you for taking my question
uh I'm somewhat t tangentially aware of
the bow case and it seems to me that
this issue of slapping a no trespassing
order on a person who was in my mind
exercising Free Speech was a
terrific uh
overreach with respect to the uh Power
of the individual who put on the no
trespass or order um are there
any provisions in the bill that would
keep somebody from putting on a no
trespass order when
they're exercising Free
Speech oh I thank you uh representative
I think I know what you're talking about
is can't should we or it do this doesn't
provide specifically for free speech
there's
no there's nothing in this in particular
about it um from what I see from other
states and I've tried to do a little
research it's not particularly fleshed
out in other states precise Provisions I
think it may it's possible that some of
these Provisions are in um chaptered law
or maybe it just says due process and
then it's up to the type of municipality
because a school board so that's why I I
handed out that um one sheet from the uh
new Hamp Northampton school they had
already you know suffered through a
lawsuit so they figured that they would
protect themselves in the future and
some of these um there's also another
one in here from Vermont and it's giv a
a lot of guidance in other words the
school guidance is different from a
library guidance different from the town
hall um and other privileged meanss
because there's some functions of the
government or public property for
instance where you don't have the public
on there like at a
um you Department of Transportation you
know um the public isn't it's a public
property but it's really not um a place
like a school where you have rights so
in other words the parents have a right
to be heard the parents have a right to
go to the uh school board meetings and
to participate in their child's
schooling um which is why the schools
some of the schools have really buttoned
down on providing a lot of these
constitutional rights to their uh to
this process whereas if you have a
Department of
Transportation garage it's not going to
be the same thing um but yeah I have not
um we don't have that in here at this
point this is just a a simple sort of in
uction to thank you fixing the problem
thanks hopefully that
helps thank you um any further questions
yeah representative rhods thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question representative I just thought
of this for a second let's say a person
was had received a no trespass order say
they went to a school board meeting and
didn't go well
right and the deliberative
session is being is taking place in the
school gym
would they be allowed to go to that
deliberative session because it's not a
a school event or would they still be
still be basically banned from going to
the
building great question um
representative roads if you look at the
back of the bow order it just says that
this subject was prohibited from
entering buildings grounds it didn't
give any car vs so so um yeah I would
think that that that person would be
arrested again if if at a at a sb2
hearing I think that we need to
understand that a trespass as regards a
property um geographically um we start
talking about go to this meeting go to
that meeting we're looking at
restraining orders say you can't be
within so many feet of a certain event
trespass means property and if we say
you can't trespass on that property it
means period you can't trespass on that
property you would be able thank you for
that clarification
trespassing well that is correct also
you have to understand you start running
into Title 18 type questions if if a
school deprives someone of their ability
to go vote that's on their property
they'd be subject to a lawsuit Federal
lawsuit for violating the person's
rights under the color of law so it it
becomes quite messy so I think narrowing
it to just the what we're doing I think
is a good idea any further questions
representative
Newman thank
you I just have a question I thought I
heard you say just a moment ago
something about it wouldn't apply to a
department of a transportation garage
for example did I mishar that oh thank
you for the um question representative
um what I I think what I was trying to
say if I didn't say it is that it is
different depending on the part the type
of public property if from what I've
read about the different cases is that
different types of property will have
different types of privileges for
instance there was a case in um I think
it's down in Kingston during the
co here um during Co when there was a
parent who was
um uh or actually it was a teacher was
thrown out of a meeting uh because she
wasn't wearing a mask um but what had
happened was the school board had
separated and put the parents in a in a
different room and they were in a
separate room there was some property it
was a privileged space so the uh Court
found that it was a privileged space
where the school board
was and um so there's there's a lot of
Nu I guess what I'm trying to say is
there's a lot of nuance to it depending
on the type of public use for instance
the um case here in
Nashua the the gentleman was outside on
the grounds so you would think that that
is probably the most liberal use of
public property that you could find is
somebody walking through public grounds
outside and then a Mor on the other end
of the spectrum you would have somewhere
some some place like a do garage or
maybe a medical type building or a
privileged type of space where the
public is not generally coming through
so you have the the spectrum of types of
space
I guess is what the courts have found
that there's there is some play and
Nuance in there which is why I didn't
want to get into making um the bill just
fit one type of thing but just a general
circumstance does that help or make
sense thank you for that explanation and
I'm just wondering how in the first
sentence where it just says Municipal
prop it says Municipal in school
district property but if it says um
any Municipal property I'm thinking that
that's all inclusive so I'm wondering if
there may be a problem there with that
in getting the Nuance recognized so that
the law could be applied so thank you I
will uh I will make a note of
that represent
Muse I just wanted to raise uh one
possibility with you too I know um uh
School rooms in particular particular
you know are not necessarily a situation
where we want you know just random folks
wandering wandering in and out um when
we talk about maybe having different
different standards for different types
of Municipal property and school
buildings are that to me would be one uh
where you would need to have an
extremely high bar and also the ability
um you know to remove anybody from a a
child's class room who's being disrupted
or really who just shouldn't be there at
all uh would you agree with that thank
you representative um yes of course I
agree with that we don't want um any
it's not a anarchistic environment that
I'm hoping to enable but just a a due
process which is it is part of the
Constitution that we provide a due
process that is that's all that this
Bill seeks to fix um but it wouldn't
preclude sort of the situation you're
talking about where obviously an
individual that doesn't belong in a
place should be removed um that's that's
how that's not going to change how that
works in our
state so see no further questions thank
you thank you very
much shair calls um
the representative
Sinclair I'm Charlie stclair I represent
District 5 Lon New Hampshire I am simply
here to say that the city manager has
reached out to me of lonier and has
informed me that both he and the uh
chief of police feel that this bill as
written would be
very hard to work
with uh with the issues they have in
lonia now that's
it thank
you thank you did they give you any more
specificity about why it would be hard
or just the the way the bill is laid out
to uh have meetings have uh call a
meeting wait for a meeting when we have
an issue that they want to deal with
right at at that time um okay so I think
that would be handled based on what I I
brought up earlier with regard to
emergency process okay thank you thank
you very much
yeah chair calls Barrett Christina
thank you chairman Roy uh good morning
members of the committee my name is
Barrett Christina I the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
boards Association we are a private
nonprofit organization that provides
services uh to school boards uh we are
opposed to House Bill 143 primarily for
some of the reasons that have already
been stated um some of your comments
chairman Roy first these no trespass
orders are are very rare in a school
context I reached out to about four or
five superintendents in preparation for
this bill and asked if they ever had do
issue one and and they had not um they
had had you know some angry parents or
some angry constituents um you know on
school grounds but they've never had to
go so far as to issue no trespass orders
second um these no trespass orders that
have been issued by some superintendent
and I have one anecdotal story uh at the
end of my testimony um need to be dealt
with immediately to address
um and the the health and and safety and
Welfare of children whether or not
that's a belligerent parent a
belligerent member of the public um but
it's usually um sort of an immediate
response to something that may be
threatening or putting Children at Risk
the third aspect um that we that I'd
like to identify too is that while we
the bill outlines a due process appeal
to the school board um superintendant
are responsible for the day-to-day
management of school grounds that's
found in RSA 194
C4 paragraph 2 um and then paragraph J
and K talks about the superintendent is
responsible for um staff student and
parent safety and building issues and
dealing with citizens at large um and
the superintendent is also responsible
for the assignment usage and maintenance
of administrative and school
facilities uh the last point that I want
to make um we have a staff attorney uh
at nhba who's been practicing law for 30
plus years representing school districts
for um a number of those he said he had
one instance where a parent who had lost
parental rights in another state showed
up at a school and the school had no
notice that that individual had lost his
parental rights and had no Advanced
knowledge of that the parent came into
the school and was belligerent and
non-cooperative pushing past um a couple
of the staff members and out of an
entrance and then ranting up and down
the hall the police in that matter would
only intervene upon the order of the
principal of that school um issuing a no
trespass order so and in that instance
there was a clear risk to the health and
safety um of students and staff members
and the police would only intervene upon
the issuance of that principal writing a
no trespass order so for those reasons
the school boards Association um opposes
the bill we don't think having a we're
having to wait for five days or a week
to for a school board to meet um it
would be would be pertinent when we're
trying to keep students safe and with
that I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you um would your
position not change if um it were
remended so that there was a procedure
for an emergency order yeah thank you
for the question chairman uh chairman
Roy I did hear you hear you mention that
I I I'd want to give it some thought
first but that certainly sounds
reasonable uh the other aspect though
you mentioned the unanimous aspect being
a high bar we would oppose we would
oppose that um we have some school
boards that have 11 13 15 people
if it's just one person that doesn't
want to one doesn't want to go along but
the other 14 people think that
individual is a is a risk to the
students we think that would should be
amended as well too and also thinking I
would also want some clarification is it
going to be unanimous of those present
in voting or is it unanimous of the
entire board and the event of board
member is not attending that meeting for
whatever reason yeah I would contemplate
a majority um anyway so great and it
would always I think due to the safety
aspect necessitate the president voting
certainly yeah okay uh representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question could you just
walk us through the process if I were to
get a a no trespass order this afternoon
what what do I do sure thank you for the
question representative I don't know if
I can if I can answer that I my
background is in school law I know
nothing about criminal law I suppose I'm
this is my own best guess representative
if you were to walk to the conquered
school and were belligerent threatening
yelling profanities the principal of
that school would issue a no trespass
order ordering you to leave and I
suppose if you did not leave or if you
came back subsequently they would call
the police and the police would come and
you would potentially be arrested I but
I don't know criminal law so I that that
would be my best guess as to how how
those
operate thank you Mr chairman do they
when you're issued that is there is it
like infinite or is it you know don't
come back for 10 days yeah certainly
that that that's a good question I think
it would have to be how how how the no
trespass order was drafted I I believe
that they can be limited time 10 days 2
weeks 30 days or I believe they can also
be
permanent sh
um could you get back to us as soon as
you can about how you would feel your
organization feel about the proposal
that uh chair Roy uh suggested having a
an emergency procedure so there could be
an immediate issuance of a a temporary
uh uh no trespass order certainly I can
I can I'll discuss that um with um
internally at our office um maybe on
Monday and get back to you Monday or
Tuesday with with an email to the
committee thank you thank
you no further questions thank you thank
you yeah share calls John
morard uh do I shall I begin I'm sorry
thank you John morard uh uh here today
uh to share uh our experience and
process at uh a large city library uh
I've been a trustee of the lonia public
library for I guess about a quarter
Century uh and chairman for uh well I'm
not sure a while I guess uh forgive me
while I try to get my magnifying glass
to agree with me
here uh so I we have uh we have a
process in place a policy a board policy
uh that addresses many of these issues
and so as it seems that your uh proposed
Bill may affect uh how we uh interface
with state law I wanted to share that
with you if I may so uh my understanding
is that uh representative bogert has
just uh passed that out to the committee
uh I won't read the whole thing this is
obviously one aspect of a larger policy
manual and the antecedence of this lay
out the groundwork for what constitutes
uh uh aggressively
uh violation aggressive violations of
our Behavior policy and how that dovet
Tales wor our mission statement so we
tried to be uh robust about that before
arriving at this particular aspect of it
but as you can see uh the lonia public
library Behavior policy may be uh
individuals who violate uh the behavior
policy may be denied access to the
library obviously we don't want to do
that if we get to the point of a no
trespass order we've effectively failed
to communicate and manage our library
the way we would otherwise wish it to be
done so that's sort of the last course
uh last remedy that we want to ever see
the duration of the no trespass orders
must be proportional to the underlying
uh misconduct such patrons will be
provided with alternative access to the
library I mean that's a little unique to
libraries but we really it it does
affect how we serve access uh to the
library uh during the no trespass order
in fact even what our appeals process
looks like because if you've no trespass
somebody then that could be an issue as
previously stated so we try to
anticipate those concerns with this
policy uh so we want people to have
access to the materials uh to the extent
that is feasible during the time of a no
trespass holder full-time Library staff
are authorized to issue the no trespass
orders on behalf of the library for a
period of up to two weeks there's an
emergency unveil unfolding in front of
you you need to be nimble to react to it
in order to protect the well-being of
the occupants of the of the premises
this is how we provided for that uh only
the director May issue a no trespass
order for 15 days that's one day longer
than the two weeks or longer the library
director will review all no tresp orders
within two weeks 14 calendar days of the
date of issuance and may adjust the
duration of the orders and I want to be
clear it does not say extend there it
says adjust perhaps it will be
lengthened perhaps it may be shortened
uh we we allow for the fact that people
might have a bad day and in the as
temper cool and the of day then maybe
maybe things can be arranged differently
we like to provide for that
opportunity uh ideally Laconia police
I'm going to actually skip this part but
you can see how we tried to dovetail
with the police department what might be
noteworthy here is that it's my
understanding that in the City of
Laconia by default a no trespass order
is issued for one year and it has been
our practice to shorten that to meet uh
paragraph one above uh but if if no
other action is taken that's the way
that works and uh
so I'm going to pick this up uh I think
uh a no trespass order may be appealed
to the library trustees in writing
within 21 calendar days the date of uh
the issuance the trustees will review
the no trespass order uh the incident
report and any other available
information such as video uh
surveillance and uh determine whether
the violations actually even occurred uh
that's you know we obviously want to
support our staff uh but we we have an
absolute
obligation to the community to provide
them with access to materials and so we
want to make sure that it really does
meet that paragraph one uh aggressively
violate the behavior policy perhaps it
does perhaps it doesn't uh the trustees
I think we did this uh whether the
violations occurred and whether a no
trespass order was reasonably Justified
a determination letter will be issued by
the trustees within 21 calendar days
after receiving uh the uh the appeal
request I'd like to add that we've had
this policy in a different form in place
for quite some time I think it's fair to
say decades uh we did uh and I'm happy
to answer this in questions later but we
did have uh a couple of opportunities
where our appeal process was invoked and
uh did seek legal counsel and one of the
reasons that this is in draft form today
is because uh Council advises us that 21
days and 21 days is too long of a
duration uh so the proposal is to reduce
that uh to perhaps again two weeks so
that is that is what we do uh as I say
we're an active Library I do have some
statistics with me I can talk a little
bit anecdotally about this if it's the
pleasure of the committee but uh that
ends my
remarks thank you um I I I mayy I I
believe um the lonia has a very um
efficient uh process in place and it
looks to me like it provides for due
process so you are to be commended um I
don't see where there is the ability to
appeal beyond that to the court but that
doesn't necessarily need to be part of
your internal process so I think it it
it's very good how many people do you
serve these orders to a year do you
think uh we serve approximately 135,000
patrons a year how many no Pro no
trespass orders uh so if you if you look
at the last five years uh less than one
100th of 1% of those the numbers are
interesting though because they tell a
story so it's it's it is as rare as it's
intended to be in Cal in this calendar
year
2025 we have served five no trespass
orders I might point out that last night
we had our first board meeting of the of
the year so uh I'm glad we didn't have
five board meetings this year this month
uh 2024 was much better we had five no
trespass orders the entire calendar year
2022 27 20216 and
20202 and those those are just the no
trespass orders we do have to a certain
degree we track uh events that might
have risen to the Le level of a no
trespass order but didn't so I'm proud
of the fact that we seem to be able to
manage that uh that difference well did
you um correlate that to certain events
going on in the library at the time that
that would um increase the number of no
trespass tress orders funny you should
to answer your question no uh but as I'm
looking at this I'm mentally trying to
correlate it and I honestly cannot it
would be interesting to see if there was
something going on within the community
or at the library at a certain time that
caused that increase and in your policy
you you allow people somehow access to
the to the books without necessarily
having access to the library is is that
what um I think that's a good policy
because sometimes people just don't fit
well around among other people but they
still should have a right to access
books which may be their only um source
of information or entertainment well one
of the things that was Paramount in our
mind when we draft this is oftentimes
there's a lot going on in someone's life
when they get to this level of duress
and access to materials that might help
them defend themselves is a is a
critical part of what our function is so
yes we do uh we have a home delivery
service we try to bring materials to
them wherever they are uh
you know if they're if they're residents
oftentimes that's a little easier than
if they're transient but uh We've we've
made we've made all the efforts we can
to do so thank you I appreciate it
questions from the
committee representative
rhs thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I'm just curious
so if this is issued do you provide an
opportunity for a public hearing that's
in writing when you're giving it to the
subject that received the
notice if I may speak
anecdotally uh in the again in the
quarter Century I've been part of the
board I've had two circumstances that
I'm aware of that have risen to what I
would call an appeal appeal level uh and
in that case when the when the most
times when no trespass orders are issued
most of the recipients have uh the
response of oh shocks you you got me
okay I'll I'll see you next year or next
week or whatever the duration is
uh in the two appeal situations uh there
was immediate push back and they wanted
to know what the process was and they
were given the Chairman's uh in my case
my personal cell phone number they
reached out to me directly uh in both
cases I met them at a a homeless shelter
uh where they were staying and I sat
with them and went through the process
uh helping them understand what what
that what that appeal how they initiated
that appeals process and then I reached
out because our no trespass was specific
about the library premises not all
municipal buildings within lonia I
arranged with the uh City manager's
office to receive the official request
which in both cases did not
happen so to clarify though on the
notice that you give them the no
trespass does it State their appeal
rights on it I I'm sorry no I do not
believe it does okay thank you thank you
see no further questions oh who repres
repr
Muse one of the things I think we've
heard in in testimonies there does seem
to be some variability between let's say
the needs of a library the needs to a
school but there do seem to be some
basic uh guardrails that need to be
there a right to do process a right to a
right to appeal um uh the addition of
something like a a temporary order
process things like that um I I noticed
that the policies that I've seen uh and
some of the policies the representative
handed us your policy they're they're
different as we draft the law we need do
would you agree that we need to keep in
mind uh the needs of different types of
Municipal and school organizations or or
different types of public
property well I'm generally speaking an
advocate of uh one siiz is not fit all
so I I see the wisdom of that for
certain uh it it's certainly not the
first time I've heard baric Christina's
voice uh name come up in a room and so I
I can say that I I do know that that
different circumstances require
different uh parameters uh the one the
one thing that you didn't really ask
this question but if I could add to it
that uh that I I wonder if
there's room for consideration is the
difference between an emergency response
and a standard protocol and I do think
as as baric Mr Christina I apologize uh
mentioned that in our case the library
director is uh responsible for running
the day-to-day operations and likewise
superintendants of schools as he pointed
out uh are that responsible party and so
having that be part of the regular
protocol so that they are already
working in the parameters that are
unique to them seems prudent to me as a
lay person uh and then that preserves
the Appellate function of the board the
school board the Board of Trustees is a
as a body and process already in place
to to react to that rather than being
the norm and then making the the UN the
uh the outlier be the emergency protocol
so I I know I went beyond your question
I hope I answered your question
representative that was actually a great
answer thank
you see you enough for the questions
thank you thank you all appreciate what
you do represent
bogar you didn't give me a card
thank you my name is Steven Bogard I am
a State Rep District 5 Laconia and I'm
also a city counselor uh Ward five
Laconia
uh I did receive a letter
from the city manager of Lone I'll I'll
pass it over at a moment and it says
please accept this letter as my
opposition to the current language
included in HB 143 this is being sent as
a result of consultation with other City
departments heads and not being sent on
behalf of the city council we have not
had time to approach the city council
with this when it was brought to our
attention so I apologize for that we
don't see the city council other than uh
looking at the
opportunities to make adjustments to the
bill we are not
against adjustments to the bill we as
the bill is written it is too closed in
to allow for emergency situations to
take place and it's as discussing this
with these
sponsors uh it was brought to our
attention if someone's breaking the law
then arrest them well there's a lot of
situations that does not require to
actually put someone in in jail in
Booking you could take people who are
having a bad moment and as the previous
document that was uh provided to
you you can put guard whs in place may
it be 5 10 15 days you have
opportunities for them to uh have a
recourse uh I do agree that the
trustpass should uh uh the trespass
notice should uh have on there what the
ability to uh ask for rehearing on this
so I do agree with that that's very
important uh but it is also important
that a department head uh the uh are in
this case in a library where you have a
lot of children you have to be able to
react immediately and and take care of
the situation so within that policy you
saw that they are
different uh avenues that parts of the
process that are taken that provide this
for the person that was given the
trespass
notice
um so the city of lonia at times must
have the opportunity to easily issue no
trespass orders on individual as
protective measures for both employees
and customer safety many of our
department heads Who oversee building
employee security have had to issue no
trespass orders and must continue to
have this option when an individual goes
to the municipal building and is causing
a significant disruption to operation
being threatening or com committing non
arrestable Petty Crim crime it is often
under law enforcement's guidance that
the best course of
action to issue a no trespass order the
order must be from the building owner
representative the ability to do this
needs to be immediate and unrealistic to
wait for a duly noticed
meeting because as you know a duly noted
meeting has to be what 10 days notice so
within 10 days there's a lot of things
that can happen while you're trying to
accomplish something the ability to do
this needs to be immediate and
unrealistic wait for duly noticed
meetings andot my department heads are
responsible for the safety of their
buildings their visitors libraries are
full of children and those who work
there taking away this ability makes
them their safety is is appropriate and
I'll hand this letter over to you when
we finished
um even though the uh no trespass order
doesn't have it within their policy they
a no trespass order may be appealed to
the library trustees in writing within
21 days that's where it's important to
have that noted on the no trespass order
the trustees will review the no trespass
order the incident report and any other
available information determine whether
the violations occurred or whether the
no transport order was reasonably
Justified a determination letter would
be issued by trustees within 21 days
after receiving the appeal
now one of the questions that came up
with uh does it say on the trespass
order that they have the ability to go
to court well that's an unspeak
ability anybody has the right to go to
court for just about anything so that's
a given in the state of New
Hampshire
um so as I
said these guidelines are are are good
guidelines you could take out the
library and and Institute a lot of
different verbiage may it be
municipalities or something like that
but it provides a guidance so that
uh towns and cities have an ability to
do something but the person that's
acting against uh is acting to get this
trespassing order has the ability to go
through these
processes with that uh I'll take any
questions see none thank you for your
testimony and if I may say one thing we
would be happy to an amendment with such
an item is this that does not restrict
everything so much so an amendment to
this uh would be agreeable thank you
we'll take that into consideration
anyone else wishing to testify in this
bill who has not done so see a none I
here by close public
hearing next one is at
12:30 next meeting is at
12:30
e
e e
183 good afternoon representative Mark
PR Hillsboro
15 uh to today I'm introducing House
Bill
which is extending the amount of
time EMTs emergency medical
personnel have to complete their state
EMS run
form
uh most of these get done on time but
where we have issues
is very busy day towards the end of the
shift it's time to go
home and if we have to fill them out
within the 24 hours we're paying
overtime for them to sit and fill out uh
which may be a
routine patient we have frequent flyers
or whatever uh I will add that if it's a
serious call they will absolutely stay
and finish that report it's just when
you have three or four routine calls um
that nobody's really going to look at
them or needs to look at them uh we're
just asking for more time I looked at
seven days because uh
some people's schedule have up to four
days in a row off and sometimes I think
there's one shift that does five days in
a row off because they they stack them
in the front and give them five days off
so that way there's plenty of time to
get it in without getting in
trouble um and with that I'll take
questions would this um well a couple
things if someone has an incident
towards the end of their shift and they
have to do this report within what does
it currently say within 24 hours yep do
they have to stay and does that cost
overtime they have to stay and cost
overtime and would you what is your
opinion throughout the course of the
year is that is we talking about a lot
of money and overtime for these reports
so you look at Statewide that's a lot of
money right I know in my department it
adds
up and as's a followup to that by doing
this it will allow First Responders to
do the report on their next scheduled
shift when they're not when they're the
clock anyway so will this amount to a
large savings you think yeah absolutely
uh cuz I I look at this if you're making
my people stay on overtime that becomes
an unfunded mandate right because you're
you're requiring them to stay after
their
shift I have to pay them or the
department has to pay them um that's an
unfunded mandate so this this bill could
lead to savings for taxpayers absolutely
thank you questions from the committee
yes represent Murphy and then I saw you
repres thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm just
thinking as a reti nurse we would often
have to do the same thing to type notes
at the end and we could be there
sometimes hours after our shift it ended
um and the the rationale for requiring
that um to be done immediately was
because over time your memory might not
recall everything and there was a
concern it would be a concern about the
the note not accurately reflecting
whatever should have been documented
what would your response be to that
concern for the same
issue so to be honest with you I I've
done some I haven't done them and did
them when I came
back uh I don't think I have dementia
yet so I think they're pretty accurate
um
and and like I said if it's a uh true
emergent call we're absolutely going to
pay the overtimes you can stay and do
your report but I I fell down and broke
my finger and I need a ride to the
hospital I think I got all those details
those are the ones that were really
looking at because to be honest with you
and we have a lot of just
routine very basic truly not emergent
they just have no other way to get to
the hospital so although all that stuff
is
pretty thank you um my other question
would be would there be anybody like if
you were not to do your notes till
whatever three days from now would there
be any um lack of patient care or would
there be any problems encountered by
somebody else as a result of not having
the information for that note who would
be using that note maybe in those three
days nobody okay as far as I know nobody
the hospital has access to our reports
um I remember
when they were first setting this up I
was in a conference call and the uh the
medical control doc was on the phone
call and this and that he wanted them
immediately because I need this
paperwork for to make my diagnosis of a
trauma victim and I came right off from
mutant said so me as a basic
EMT you as a trauma doctor need to step
out after I finish writing my report in
the ER read it and make your diagnosis
is that what you're telling
me and all I heard was
crickets I said so right you're not even
going to read my report are you he goes
yeah probably not right so I don't
believe anybody is is
looking at these especially on those
routine calls sure I'm sure if we
brought in and even still we have 24
hours to do
it so if I bring them in at 6:00 a.m.
and I don't write it till 6:00 a.m.
tomorrow the hospital has already
started treating that and the other
piece of that is pretty much everything
I'm going to put in my report I hand off
to the nurse in the Ed right I give her
all that report I rip off my 12 lead
give her that give her everything and we
answer questions and what have you and
off we go and I'm going to tell you most
of this stuff is used for our
billing thank you billing and perhaps
insurance claims later well that's
that's what I mean yeah I mean insurance
investigations later on if there was a
payout or something um representative
Harry gathre
thank you for taking my question um
would you have a problem with say 48
hour I mean 48 yeah 48 Hours 3 days I'm
going to tell you because it they have
four days
off oh after incident right so if it's
on
my some of them are working like 24 on
24 off 24 on 4 days
off so if if it's at that last shift
they're going to be gone for four four
days right well I guess it's you're
leaving on one and you're coming back on
the morning of that fourth day right
something like that okay right even with
that I just think seven days you want to
do five time you know I'll do
five because it's four days right so
yeah so I always like to build in a
little
extra you're quite
aor yeah yeah I just think I put I put
seven cuz if they're sick that first day
they'll be back on that second and that
seventh day
right I can go with
five representa
pette okay any further questions yes
represent M sorry thank you I'm I'm just
thinking I agree with a little shorter
time frame I recognize we understanding
that many calls are repetitive and there
are people well known to you with the
same problem over and over that said um
if we're going to put it in into we're
going to legislate this then should
there be just a little bit more concise
parameters
around which types of incidents can wait
five days and which can't like you said
you would just because you're a
responsible person you would always
complete something on a on a bigger deal
than a maybe a fractioned finger or
something but could this this would just
leave it to cop launch I mean you could
have a major trauma and still not have
to do that so our our call levels are
alpha yeah bravo charlie delta yeah and
Echo right so Alpha is minor Bravo is
just a little bit above you
know Alpha is usually standing at the
curb with their baggage Bravo they have
a bleed on my finger that I have to stop
Charlie you kind of getting there
so Delta and Echo you're in serious
trouble so I would say Delta and Echo
have to be done okay yeah and then the
others can wait is that Alpha phonetic
categorization a a Statewide thing
absolutely everybody knows that's how n
911 dispatches them and that's how we uh
correlate I was going to suggest if if
not that leave some type of management
prerogative where it just said whoever
unless at the direction of the senior um
the report can be done within so many
days yeah something someone where
someone could the boss could say n that
one I think I'm I'm going to hear from
usually what happens
anyway I mean if there's a a bad call
who's ever in charge that of that shift
won't let anybody leave until all the
paperwork's
done any further questions um maybe the
people who ask the questions could work
together with you to get it amended so
we can execute in a week or so all right
thank
you anyone else wish to testify on this
bill has it done so I see you attracted
a big crowd there all your friends
showed uping up the show
so and with that I close the public
hearing and we are back again at
1:30 yeah but I we told them no no
that's
fine next time we know because I think
Ross is doing something else today cuz
he told me he was here for something
else but he was going to come over at
three
e
e e
I am opening to public hearing on House
Bill
291 regarding
fertilizer and I ask the prime sponsor
to please explain
this thank you Mr chairman for the
record I am Erica Leon representing the
town of dairy
um I'm Vice chair of executive
departments and administration and jail
car um and I bring this bill to you
because for those of you who are around
last year you probably don't remember
the bill about fertilizer application
going through the normal process you
don't remember when it um passed through
um ex environment and agriculture on the
consent calendar and moved over to the
Senate you don't remember when it went
through there quietly and easily because
a lot of this makes
but you probably do remember when we had
to override the governor's veto so the
governor vetoed the bill um because for
a few
reasons uh I included The veto message
on what I passed around and he said
despite this bill's well sought
intention to reduce fertilizer
contamination it contains several
unworkable and impractical Provisions
rather than focus and he talks about the
focus it says this would put countless
well-meaning families unintentionally in
violation of the law when maintaining
their privately owned laws so this law
doesn't apply to golf courses athletic
fields or Parks but it applies to your
lawn and if you did some homework and
looked at what this bill is doing and
which section of law it touches you
wouldn't have found it because this law
is in effect and you can get a
misdemeanor for putting the wrong
fertilizer on your law but since we
overlo overrode The veto back in October
it doesn't even show up on the general
court website yet so you if you're using
last year's fertilizer putting on your
lawn your neighbor knows about this law
and TS you in you could be charged with
a
misdemeanor so what we need to come back
to is sort of what happened with this
bill um they put it in the soil
amendment section and the section on
fertilizers which always dealt with
people who manufacture fertilizers and
sell fertilizers in the past so the
penalties in that chapter are
misdemeanors for natural persons and
felonies for all others because if your
business is in the wrong fertilizers
especially if you're mislabeling them
that's a serious problem and that
deserves misdemeanor or felony this
section for the first time in the
statute deals with your average everyday
person now your average everyday person
who's putting on fertilizer they bought
last year could be charged with a
misdemeanor and that just does not seem
to be the correct level of punishment
for adding a little more phosphorus than
we want to see especially if it's not if
it you know yeah so you don't want to be
you don't want to be over fertilizing
you don't want to be having this runoff
that's causing cyanobacteria
blooms but you shouldn't have this be a
misdemeanor so all this bill does is it
says that if you're violating this new
section that applies to the average
everyday Granite Stater it's a violation
and not a
misdemeanor thank you questions from the
committee yes representative um I can't
pronounce it
thank you chairman Roy representative s
here thank you for taking my question um
representative Leon is there evidence of
any enforcement of this as it is right
now as it stands um so that's a great
question it actually came into law back
in January 1st is because it has a
criminal penalty it wouldn't take effect
until the beginning of the year and I
don't know about you but it's definitely
not fertilizer season at my house with a
snow pack over it so nobody's fertilized
it yet and it ALS so it also isn't uh
online but the question too becomes do
we want to have misdemeanor sitting
around sprinkled in our statutes that we
expect will never be enforced because
then you could have selective
enforcement there's the chance that you
may have a neighbor who really really
hates you uh and they saw that your
fertilizer is the wrong level and so
they turn you into the Department of
Agriculture and we really shouldn't be
getting in the middle of uh neighbor
disputes by doing things like that thank
you thank you man
it it seems to me that we shouldn't be
getting in the middle of me and Home
Depot if I go buy a bag of fertilizer I
shouldn't have to worry about whether or
not um it's a crime right so can you
explain to me a little bit what what
what this means like if I go buy a
fertilizer at Lowe's or Home Depot do I
have to make sure that they haven't sold
me a product that could be a violation
um that's a good question I would hope
that Lowe's and Home Depot are had were
paying attention into this and are
actually selling the correct fertilizer
if they aren't I'm fine with them facing
those penalties for selling it but your
real question is if you live in a Border
Town and you don't really care about
paying the sales tax in Massachusetts
you needed fertilizer on your way home
and you buy your fertilizer there you
might be buying a legal fertilizer and
you wouldn't look you wouldn't expect a
check for that yeah
okay so this changes any penalty that a
homeowner would have to a violation
correct okay thank you further questions
from the committee representative
Sher uh given uh that uh the effective
date on this is January 1st of 2026
might it make more sense to uh change
the effective date to when the bill is
signed by the governor so that if it's
possible that it can be in place for
this summer um if it I I would love that
if that's possible I this committee
deals with the criminal penalties a lot
more than I ever have in my experience
this is the way it was written by OS but
if it's possible to remove a crime
without having to wait for the end of
the year as opposed to adding a crime
which makes sense to wait I I would very
be very appreciative to to that friendly
Amendment such to the uh uh in
difference to the chair I I
believe uh we can decide when it's going
to go be effective it's up to us yeah it
will change the effective date to um
upon
signage any further questions yes repres
Murphy Oh Thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question if as I'm reading this this
only applies to lawn within 25 feet of a
storm drain not not um bodies of water I
mean there's no question that CYO
bacteria is causing a huge issue in the
state and lots of cost to to to address
that um so is this is just in that
particular sit situation are we talking
about so those are the governor's words
from the governor's veto yeah um when I
read it um it actually looked
like there we go thank you I look like
it could apply more broadly um I I don't
know and it's also bodies of water so we
have a stream that sometimes runs
through our yard because it's seasonal
so if it has one of those if somebody
determines that something is a rivulet
because so much much of the wetlands is
really complex and detailed and it's
tough for us let alone your average
homeowner um the big question I I fully
agree with you on the cyanobacteria I
believe we were both on the
environmentally triggered chronic
illness committee together so I
understand the need to protect our
Waters and to prevent this from going
into our Watershed I just don't believe
that having a misdemeanor for the
individual applying it as opposed to
somebody selling that fertilizer is an
appropriate uh is an appropriate
punishment
thank you um so I'm just thinking in the
situation where you might be Lakefront
community and a and um your particular
lake is the the phosphorus content is
increasing and the Ceno bacteria blooms
um
if what would happen if if uh the you
know the the particular lakeef fromont
Community recognizes that it's
fertilizer from you know people's Lawns
that are causing it and the request is
made to everybody for not to not use a
particular uh fertilizer because of the
cost to all of the the inability to use
the lake um and the risk to Public
Health if that's repeated I mean if if
people don't comply with that and this
we're exacerbating a problem that we
already know is is a is a huge issue do
you feel that there should be a a um
legal recourse is like just a
misdemeanor if people continue to do
that or do you
um so I'll make up a hypothetical
scenario let's say Mr Robert Moneybags
lives on the lake in the most expensive
house in the state and he really wants
his Green Lawn all the way up to the
edge and he doesn't care and he puts
100% phosphorus would actually kill the
grass but he puts whatever high level
there
is there might be an issue on repeated
violations because to him that's just
the cost of lawn care but especially for
a first violation it should be violation
maybe on the second or third um to have
it be a misdemeanor that would be
reasonable but on the first time that
that this has come in front of anything
I really think that the first one at
least needs to be a violation if you
believe that it needs to be a
misdemeanor after you already had a
violation that's something that I that I
could live with but I can't live with it
being a misdemeanor to put the wrong
fertilizer on when you may have bought
it in Massachusetts it didn't know any
better thank thank you you're
welcome representative Murphy if you
would like to um get an amendment that
changes the effective date and adds a u
misdemeanor on the second and third
offense or an increased fine for the
second and misdemeanor for the third we
do that representative uh
Muse in the bill I notice you don't
differentiate uh between a homeowner and
let's say someone like a landscaping
company so uh in your example Mr money
bags probably isn't putting his own
fertilizer down it's probably somebody
else who puts a lot of fertilizer down
and a lot of Lawns do you think the law
should treat folks like that any
differently well thank you that's a good
question and you also want to look at
sort of the ecosystem of lawn care
there's some of the big commercial lawn
care companies but there's also I'm
encouraging my boys who are here today
that maybe they might want to get into
lawn care when they're old enough to be
doing that and if they're mowing some
people's Lawns and they put a little bit
too much fertilizer I would say them or
some of the people in my community where
there's one a oneman landscaping uh
business or a Twan landscaping business
probably shouldn't be treated the same
way as the large one if we added a
penalty we're on the second or where you
escalated the fine on the second and
then made it a misdemeanor on the third
then you're looking at an issue where a
large company that's doing this across
the state and doing it on lots of Mr
Moneybags properties um would still have
to comply and they'd be dealing with the
misdemeanors but we'd be letting the
average citizen um have a softer hand
from the state thank
you U representative Harry
gather thank you for taking my question
um did did you have any data that this
is this is actually a problem
here um thank you for the question we
just overrode the governor's veto back
in October and it's not fertilizing
season yet so nobody's had the
opportunity to over fertilize yet but I
I have a big problem with laws that are
on the books that would that have the
potential to be selectively enforced
especially with criminal penalties um I
think that that just invites the
opportunity for misuse um
and I I think that having that having
laws that are selectively enforced with
a high penalty like a misdemeanor is
really
unjust thank
you thank you one last question
um right now is Dees the enforcement
Authority and would that be the same for
this or I just I just recognize the the
challenges we've had in in terms of
availability of Staffing just to even
test foro bacteria at our our Lakes
because of of Staffing for dees are they
the persons that would be responsible
for well um so while I have some
editorial questions about the governor
saying that it's only within the 25 ft
in The veto message he says that the
Department of Agriculture reports that
the enforcement of the law would be
entirely relying on neighbors telling
neighbors because they don't have the
people to staff to go around and ask to
see your bag and see what the phosphorus
content is so it would be Department of
Agriculture and you're right we're
already asking our agencies to do a lot
of things and there's a lot of really
important things that we need
agriculture to do that this would be
taking away from their larger
Mission but if you had somebody who's a
repeat violator at that point when when
the Moneybags grass company keeps doing
this around the state that becomes a
high priority because it's a repeated
issue and and it does say they are
personally or through an agent so I
would think the agent would be the
company or or that's my that's my
intention thank you just to be clear we
don't have anything against the
Moneybags company per
se representative uh Murray would like
to read something that will clarify this
a little bit for us from the statue yes
thank you Mr chair um I pulled up an
official notice from the Department of
Agriculture that they put out this past
December so it says restrictions for the
use of turf fertilizer for homeowners
and Commercial users and then it says it
prohibits application within 25 ft of
water or storm drains or where it can
enter storm drains application during or
immediately before heavy rain
application where grass is not actively
growing including frozen ground and
impervious services and then it lists
the rsas gives people a list um or a
link to go look for more information and
it also has a great description of um
going over the basics of cyanobacteria
so that hopefully you know when people
get this notice they have a full picture
of what they're supposed to do and
why thank you that's helpful any further
questions for the sponsor seeing none
thank you thank
you the chair calls representative Aaron
good afternoon committee chair and
members of the uh criminal justice
committee thank you so much for uh
hearing this bill this afternoon and I
am representative Judy Aaron I am chair
of environment and agriculture committee
as well as uh representing svin County
District 4 which is aworth Goan langon
lster and Washington and I just wanted
to come today just very briefly to let
you know that I do support the this bill
as
co-sponsor um this bill did come out of
my committee last year and and sort of I
guess as an
oversight uh I we were not aware of the
criminal penalties being so so Stern so
I do support um making this a violation
as opposed to misdemeanor and U that's
really all I wanted to come and say and
I reiterate and support everything that
representative Lon had just laid out to
you
thank you we appreciate it and the work
that your committee did to bring It
Forward um any questions seeing none
thank you thank
you um the lay on
boys I think that it if if that if
putting INF fertilizer on wrong is on
the same level of a DUI which is is from
something that can actually kill
someone that something needs to change
with that law and it needs to uh be a
much lower and it needs to be in a a
lower category than
that thank you what do you think the
punishment should
be
violation okay well how much should the
fine be you think I don't know how much
is your
allowance I'm not I you don't get one I
I just was improving this today so so I
I don't know okay all right well think
about it and get back to us shouldn't
the chair uh uh inform the witness of
his Fifth Amendment
privilege yeah exactly with his with his
mom here thank you very much for coming
forward today we appreciate it and we
will take your words on
advisement the chair calls Andrea laru
from the New Hampshire Lake
Association right thank
you good good afternoon happy Friday to
you all I know you've had a busy long
week uh I'm Andrea Laro the president
and policy advocate for New Hampshire
lakes and I'm here today um technically
to speak to oppose this belill but to
oppose it as it's written um and I've
been really encouraged by all the
discussion that has been happening thus
far um and we would agree that um it
would be appropriate to downgrade um the
penalties um you know violation seems
appropriate what we're concerned about
and you may have seen online about 150
folks from The Late Community Road in uh
we would like to see that there is some
sort of fine um attached to this for
just what's been mentioned the repeated
knowing um you know violation of the law
and I I really appreciate the thoughtful
discussion and your concerns about
cyanobacteria so I'd be happy to answer
any questions and it would be really um
supportive of an amendment to what's
been
discussed as the concern from your
Association that you may have um an
owner who just doesn't really care and
just has the money to afford a little
fine we'll just keep ignoring it is that
pretty much that is the concern and
unfortunately we do see that type of
behavior throughout the state and we're
concerned that if it's a violation with
really no deterrent um that you know it
kind of doesn't really have any teeth
well we will we will add some Dentures
thank you Dentures thank you so much and
and have I'll see you later actually
this afternoon very anyone have a
question before she goes seeing none all
right thank you thank you is there
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill who has not testified or was turned
into a card seeing none I hereby closes
public
hearing the next one's at two right 230
e
e e
hereby open the public hearing on
Hospital 218 and invite the prime
sponsor to approach and introduce the
bill
good afternoon Mr chairman my name is uh
John T McDonald I'm from Cal district 6
and I represent the fine people from the
communities of wolf bro and tufton bro
New Hampshire I want to thank you and
the committee for the opportunity to
introduce HB 218 with the requested
amendment of 2025
-005 it is important for us to remember
that crimes can happen to innocent
people of all ages sex and race within
on New Hampshire communities these
individuals become a victim in a system
that they may have little or no
knowledge of or aware of any guaranteed
rights they may have as victim of crime
in New Hampshire when I started my law
enforcement career over 40 plus years
ago victims lacked any clear
well-defined and guaranteed victim
rights victims in cases were excluded
from the courtroom not able to speak at
sentencing not notified of Court
proceedings or of the arrest or release
of the person who committed the crime
against them not provided with the
needed guidance support for such crimes
as domestic violence sexual assault and
other serious crimes there are also a
very limited number of Victim Assistance
programs available throughout our state
due to the hard workor of victims victim
Advocates members of the public law
enforcement and a judicial system New
Hampshire passed the rights of Crime
Victims found in RSA
21-m
8-k which I believe you should have a
copy of in addition to the passing of
this law funding from the federal state
local and donations from the public
resulted in the opening of numerous new
and specialized Victim Assistance
programs within our state the passing of
the rights of Crime Victims law was a
major step forward in ensuring
guaranteeing the rights of victims which
included the protection against the
criminal offense
availability of needed services to meet
both their emotional and physical needs
and a clear explanation of the workings
of the criminal justice system in New
Hampshire this bill SL Amendment adds
one new right to the current law that
being within 60 days upon request
request the right to be provided a copy
of the complete police report without
charge following the closure of the case
by either the investigating or
Prosecuting agency any confidential
information that may be contained in the
report can be redacted by the law
enforcement agency prior to the reing of
the report to the victim the defendant
who was accused of a crime and through a
court process is provided a free copy of
the complete police report along with
any exculpatory evidence in conclusion
let's not make victims take money out of
their own pockets for copy of a preious
report for a crime that was committed
against them if I can just add uh Mr
chairman uh prior to the hearing I met
with uh uh the representative from the
New Hampshire Chiefs Association and
also the New Hampshire Sheriff
Association and the uh uh representative
from the New Hampshire State Police uh
after talking to them they've got a few
ideas on how we can better fine-tune uh
this this amendment of this bill and if
possible I'd like to request uh that you
appoint a subcommittee uh to work with
us to get a really good Bild to come on
a
committee thank you um and I I believe I
will do just that does anyone have any
questions for the sponsor where we have
them
here okay seeing none um I will appoint
a subcommittee and I will let you know
who they are by the end of the day thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee
members chair calls Pamela
colleague
okay that's all we need these two
people I'm going to just before you
start the the subcommittee on this is
going to consist of two people it's
going to be representative Murphy and
representative
rhods uh good afternoon uh Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
Pamela kyg and I am the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence um I'm here to speak in support
of HB 218 um as you heard from the
sponsor this bill updates RSA 21 m8k the
status uh the statute governing the
rights of Crime Victims in New Hampshire
and would allow uh victims of crime to
access their police reports for free at
the completion of an investigation um I
think it's just this is an important
policy because Crime Victims should not
have to foot the bill to receive the
police report in their own case um just
a quick point of clarification to um
this um St uh this bill wouldn't
conflict with any other statute um and
then also under 91a um the victims
already um have access to their police
report um but with this bill they
wouldn't be charged um so this shouldn't
add any major changes to our state law
um so I think something I just wanted to
highlight and I'll keep this brief
because I know there's going to be a
step study committee um but victims
often need copies of police reports to
access um services and their rights um
and this could include filing an
insurance claim use in legal proceedings
uh requesting assistance through
victim's compensation programs um for
employers to meet eligibility
requirements and also landlord tenant
matters as well as other things um and
so this means that a victim's ability to
receive their police report in a timely
manner can have a direct impact on their
ability to meaningfully access their
statutory rights as well as the
assistance they are entitled um as a
result of their
victimization um and I think passing
this bill will eliminate an unnecessary
cost to victims in New Hampshire and
offset the cost of abuse in general um
and I'm happy to work with uh the
sponsor of the bill and our our
colleagues in the back um to fine-tune
the bill just to make sure that um it
works with all parties involved so thank
you so much and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you um I meant to ask
the sponsor this but it seems to me 60
days is an awful long time to have to
wait for a report and maybe the
subcommittee can look into if there's a
specific reason why law enforcement
needed that much time um but I would
think that we could do it quicker than
that uh repres representative uh
representative Sher uh would you have
any problem with well my concern a
language concern there's no such thing
in a case as a police report every case
has a whole bunch of police reports so
for the subcommittee's purpose I think
it'd be better do you think it would be
better to read uh be provided with a
copy of a complete set of police reports
in the case that would better
characterize the circumstance otherwise
some police departments are going to
read this
as okay we need to get one police report
yeah no thank you so much for the
question and I know um someone from the
state police is here and I think they
could speak to that and we can
definitely look at making sure the
language is um very clear so thank you
any further questions seeing none thank
you thank you very
much uh chair calls um major Wright
you didn't get promoted D you're still
major right yes okay I have no interest
in anything anything more
so all I appreciate you hearing my
testimony uh just for the record my name
is Bill brigh I am a major with the New
Hampshire State Police um we um are in
support of uh you know the idea of this
bill and and uh providing reports to
victims uh at no cost um the
conversations that we've had um kind of
uh fall under more like the the more
sizable reports so as you know uh cases
come in all different shapes and sizes
um so if you think of a homicide case
that may include you know 10,000 40,000
pages of of documents may include uh
digital files um you know whether that's
audio video um surve video and so we're
just looking to clarify with the
representative and the subcommittee um
how that would actually work what was
what is what is required what's needed
and then uh what it would take to
provide that so to answer your question
about the 60 days that is that is a uh
you know a lengthy time for a small
report but the reality is for a a large
report we may need more time so I'm not
sure what the wording should be or if we
should stick stick with the 60 days but
we're we're willing to work uh with the
committee to to come up with a good uh a
good bill that to come out of it perhaps
a standard time with a relief valve
where if it because I was just thinking
yeah
redactions uh a lengthy homicide Report
with redactions could take 60 days just
to get that squared away yeah under the
91a uh request that we get for the
larger cases we it's often uh much
longer than 60 days for us to provide
that for those reasons yeah providing
redactions of thousands of pages uh can
take some time okay all right well I'll
leave it to the subcommittee to to work
with you to figure that out excellent
thank you yes go
ahead yes thanks for taking my question
um does the right to no law cover police
reports yes
so would a victim have more rights to
police reports than the average citizen
uh not necessarily under the under the
91a law I don't believe so uh which I
think is the you know the intention of
this bill okay
so uh followup y so what we're what
we're doing with this bill is giving the
the victim additional
rights above and beyond the right to no
law yes there some I guess an
acknowledgement that uh those reports
will be provided at no cost okay thank
you yeah just so my understanding is
that it really doesn't give them any
more rights it just charges it just
waves the fee okay and and it it's it
might shorten a time frame yeah every
agency is different I believe under the
91a law um you can be charged to receive
those reports um but not every agency
does that um it depends on on the case
too and and what it takes to to provide
it yeah exactly I imagine an accident
report versus a you know B and E there'
be a big difference correct okay thank
you thank you anyone else is there
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill who has not testified yet seeing
none I hereby Clos the public hearing on
Hospital 218 and we Rec conven at 3
o'cl
e
e e
I'm hereby opening the public hearing on
House Bill 397 and invite the prime
sponsor to introduce the
Bill thank you chair Roy um honorable
members of the criminal justice ice and
Public Safety Committee my name is
representative will Derby I'm from uh
Hillsboro District 11 nashille award
8 as a quick overview this bill is to
address a uh an issue a persistent issue
that we've heard um in the resources
committee um on during numerous uh
public hearings which is that uh the
lack of Marine Patrol on New Hampshire's
water bodies as some background that I
think some people people are familiar
with the the um outdoor tourism in New
Hampshire is a significant State
industry it brings um tourism in general
brings in over 325 million annually in
tax revenue and outdoor tourism
specifically brings in 3.9 billion to
the state economy we have over a
thousand public lakes and ponds and
that's a which are a major public uh
summer tourist
attraction we've heard numerous uh Lake
related bills in resources um and 's a
common theme across many of these from
uh from both sides of on many of the
positions which is that there's not
enough Marine
Patrol my own story is that I've had a
uh camp on lake monomac in ringe which
is right on the Massachusetts border for
about 10 years um when we first were
there every weekend we would see Marine
Patrol on the water body um just sitting
there very rarely issuing teates but
making sure that um that uh
that uh boating was safe um the
Recreations on the lake were safe and
that the lake could be enjoyed by
all uh over the years that's diminished
until last year I didn't we didn't see
um Marine Patrol a single day on our
Lake what we saw instead was outrageous
behavior like jet skis jumping over the
wakes uh directly behind wake Surfers
unregistered watercraft ski craft coming
from the Massachusetts portion of the B
of the water which are not permitted on
the New Hampshire side
and out of state voters that didn't
carry the invasive species decal that
helps offset the costs of uh invas
fighting invasive species in New
Hampshire of course the vast majority of
of boter are responsible and as we hear
again and again Ed education is
essential informing V informing
violators of the of the infractions uh
prevents them in the future and
oftentimes education's enough tickets
don't even need to be issued
um and as we've all seen people are more
responsible when law enforcement is
present we've all seen uh police police
car on the side of the road people slow
down people are um people don't run stop
lights for
example ultimately conflicts on the lake
can be minimized if we um and we can
have better balance for the multiple
uses of the public waterways with just
the presence of Marine
Patrol funding is not the issue there's
uh numerous positions um in in Marine
Patrol go unfunded every year and this
is particularly uh uh true of the
seasonal positions um in the summer um
recruiting is also not the problem uh
Department of Safety has extensive
programs to recruit staff for multiple
sources colleges um and uh number of
other sources and other people have
suggested that training might be the
problem but there is no magic bullet
I've to spoke to many members of the
Department of Safety including assistant
commissioner Ed
and there's if there was a bill that we
could bring forward that would solve
this problem more money as many people
have suggested of course that's what we
would have brought forward but that's
not what the issue
is originally I had int planned for a
study committee um I was on a study
committee over the summer to study
fishing game Partnerships and I found
that there was great bipartisan uh
collaboration and we heard from a broad
uh a broad set of
stakeholders but when I spoke to uh
assistant commissioner Edwards he
suggested a task force instead said that
um the they had success with past task
force task forces and that they had some
suggestions on on uh they wanted some
time to think about some suggestions for
legislation they could bring forward
task force are public meetings as well
legislators can attend um provide
comments the public can it as well
ultimately the goal is um uh for the
task force to um to Pro propose
legislation that we can evaluate um to
increase law enforcement patrols on New
Hampshire water
bodies the question that some people
might ask is is this bill actually
necessary can't the department of safety
just do this on their own I'd answer
that by saying the problem is getting
worse every year like I described
earlier and there's an outcry of users
um across um of the variety of users
that use the Lakes both Lake
Associations on social media and at
public hearings ultimately I think that
the department safety would benefit from
Direction by the legislature to address
the shortage of Marine
Patrol why is it a multi- agency task
force well there's other agencies that
have responsibilities both for
patrolling as well as protecting New
Hampshire water bodies fishing game for
example RSA uh
20626 um paragraph 11 talks about um uh
the two enforce the laws relating to
amongst other thing boats they also have
broad enforcement UH responsibilities
including the uh uh ability to enforce
all provisions of RSA title uh 21
relative to Motor Vehicle Laws why the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services because they run
the um a program called the New
Hampshire Lakes management Protection
Program the summary of that is that it
was created by the legislature to um as
a result of the recognition of competing
uses of the state surface waters um to
to um make sure that biological social
and economic assets are being
protected ultim um this will also engage
other stakeholders and experts Municipal
and County Law Enforcement that protect
water uh Public Safety on lakes um as
well as um other Representatives like
Marine trades New Hampshire lakes and
the Len preservation committee I have
spoken to most most of those groups and
they're interested in supporting
us the qu the question that this task
force would be answering is what are the
needs for law enforcement patrols and
how can those needs be met by maximizing
the available resources federal dollars
are also of
question is there being is there being
money left on the table because of the
unfulfilled positions unfilled positions
which has been is is a refrain I've
heard as well over all and to summarize
um the intent of this bill is for
experts to provide recommendations on
how to address the problem of
insufficient Marine patrols so residents
and tourists can fully enjoy New
Hampshire treasured Lakes thank you very
much and of course I'm happy to take any
questions thank you for that
introduction and for bringing this spill
forward I I got to tell you I'm I'm
familiar with Lake monomac I grew up in
winchington so I know the area well in
the lake um and I also know the
Massachusetts end I think is pretty much
weeded over every year by by May yeah
yeah um I appreciate any questions from
the
committee see none thank you very
much
oh
glad the chair calls Andrea Laro
good afternoon again I'm Andrea Laro
president and policy advocate of New
Hampshire lakes and we are a Statewide
nonprofit organization our mission is to
restore and preserve the health of our
Lakes we represent about 275 local Lake
Associations we're here to speak in
support of this bill you may have seen
if you went to the online um testimony
signin about 15
Lake residents and Lake Association
members uh are urging you to support
this bill for many of the reasons that
representative Darby uh just said I have
been um working with lakes and Lake
management and preservation here in New
Hampshire since 2001 I started over at
the Department of Environmental Services
and the biggest um thing I hear uh that
I've heard from our constituents um over
the years is uh where is Marine Patrol
um there is a period of years where it
seemed to be
relatively uh some decent coverage of
the Marine Patrol but as of late the
past several years it seems that uh the
presence of Marine Patrol um on our
Lakes has decreased at least that's what
I'm hearing and that's a current concern
for us of course for safety reasons and
also uh just law enforcement in general
helping to enforce water quality laws
out on the water as well so we urge you
to support this and and if if we are
organization were asked to come um talk
to the task force we of course would be
happy to do so so with that I'd be happy
to answer any
questions any
questions uh yes repres I
Muse I noticed that in the bill all of
the folks on the task force are actually
in law enforcement um would it be
helpful to have your Association and
some of the other folks who represent
people who actually live along the Lakes
uh being part of that task force or is
it enough just to go to the public
meetings that's a great question I I did
see that groups like myself um our group
would be invited and I think that alone
would be helpful um if if we were asked
to sit on the group U we asked to sit on
a lot of groups and we do and of course
we would make someone available but I
think having a venue to at least come
and visit and and answer questions and
provide ideas would be
helpful representative shear
thank you anyone else see no further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank
you the chair calls Tim
dunlevy good afternoon chairman Roy
honorable members of the committee my
name is Tim Dunley and I'm here today
representing the Department of Safety uh
the Marine Patrol unit of the State
Police I come today in support of this
bill the department of safety recognizes
the intent that um representative Darby
brings uh uh to you folks in the form of
the bill it recognizes its
responsibilities to chair the task force
and frankly um they thought that perhaps
the task force where State Police is
currently working to do what they can to
uh increase the coverage um
open to other ideas but but have ideas
of their own and and they believe that
this task force approach is likely the
better route to take I'm happy to answer
any questions you folks might have of us
thank you um are you are you
experiencing a shortage in staff
currently is is that part of the the
issue here yes sir Mr chairman is as you
probably know um and have heard the last
Fistful of years uh the ability to
recruit law enforcement officers in our
country never mind our state never mind
uh to a seasonal operation that Marine
Patrol is has been a challenge for
agencies and we are no exception yeah I
actually put in a bill this year we're
going to be hearing next week um to
establish a commission to study the
shortage in law enforcement and ways we
might be able to recruit more people to
the field so I do understand that and
and it's my understanding that there may
be a couple of other bills like that
floating around this session that that
uh I think um is is really the Crux to
the issue and and uh if this task force
can look specifically at ways that
Marine Patrol can can recruit and and um
get the coverage that that it's um
trying now creatively to increase uh
will help okay maybe we need to start
rerunning reruns of northwards law or
something people involv um any further
questions yes representative
so thank you for taking my question um
are you familiar with the the program
Northwoods
law thank you for the question
representative yes
sir in my mind Northwoods law is could
be a chamber of commerce advertisement
for the State of New Hampshire and I've
made this suggestion to other agencies
that are in in uh Manpower shortages to
expand their their horizons with respect
to their recruitment efforts and
apply some effort to recruiting people
that are getting out of the military
service a lot of people who are getting
out of the military service have
wonderful experience but
also uh maybe do not have Roots
anywhere uh the New Hampshire uh uh
lifestyle is very appealing for a lot of
these young folks and I would encourage
you to somehow find a way of tapping
into that resource have you ever thought
of that before that's the
question thank you representative yes I
can assure you that uh uh our our uh
military folks that are that are coming
out of service whether it's a retirement
or have just Ser made their served their
commitment uh are absolutely a Target of
ours in fact we just hired two coming
out of the Coast Guard for full-time
positions that had been vacant for
several years so we are we are tapping
into that resource uh we are tapping
into um uh when when the state police
recruits for Trooper positions 90% of
the time there's a Marine Patrol uniform
at that table or that Booth um
recruiting
alongside one of the things we're
dealing with is is sortly the SE
seasonal nature of of our Patrol Force
but that the state police is looking at
uh recently the last couple of years
have employed what they've referred to
as the joint enforcement of the jet team
where they're actually um taking
advantage of of Road Troopers uh on
their off time to come and and work
Patrol shifts on the water so the the
the creative thinking is there uh and
certainly with time and and uh attention
to this the state police is is anxious
to to improve it uh in any way they
can my son was actually a marine patrol
officer for a while many people don't
don't know this but Marine Patrol
officers go through the police
academy and uh so they are law
enforcement officials you're absolutely
correct seeing none thank you for coming
today thank you all for your time y
anyone else is there anyone else who has
not testified on this bill that would
wish to testify seeing none I hereby
Clos public hearing on House Bill
397 with that I'm going to open the
executive session on House Bill
511 and I recognize myself to introduce
an amendment you should all have a copy
of it the amendment number is 2025 0079
H
Hotel make a motion to introduce the
amendment Amendment
second motion seconded by representative
PR I believe everyone has had this
amendment now for over an hour I think
you've had time does anyone have any
comments on the amendment they'd like to
make seeing none I'd ask the clerk to
call the role in the amendment the
motion is ought to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative LEL
yes representative void yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative pette yes representative
saorin D sha
yes representative Barry yes
representative Harriet Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chotes yes 160 160 the motion is uh
to adopt is passed um I recognize to
myself to makeing a motion of ought to
pass as amended for House Bill
511 second seconded by representative
rhods is anyone wish to make a comment
or discuss seeing none un that's cler to
call the role the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment with Amendment Vice
chair roads yes representative PR yes
representative LEL yes representative
devoid yes representative Sweeny yes
representative pette yes representative
Sabor D yes representative Barry yes
representative harri Gite representative
Muse yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Shear yes chairman Roy
chair VES yes 160 160 the motion passes
any objection to cons on consent
seeing none we'll go on to consent
calendar thank you for your service I'll
see you next
week yeah right no comment no discussion
mile
e
e e